the Llama herd has left the building and
is roaming the streets more specifically
the Llama 3.1 405 billion parameter
language model is out but I thought the
former expression would be a bit more
dramatic the 92 page paper that came
with the model was released less than 24
hours ago and yes I've read it in full
and have benchmarked the model comparing
it to four competitors on over a 100
private questions
with 74 notes to touch on the model is
impressive and the paper is revealing so
let's get started there are three sizes
of text only llama 3 models but this
video will focus almost entirely on the
biggest and best the 405 billion
parameter model and no meta weren't
exaggerating when they say that it
delivers comparable quality to Leading
language models such as gpc4 and in case
you're new to the Channel I'm not just
relying on those traditional benchmarks
to assess that comparison meta's
Innovations in a nutshell were higher
quality data that's filtered for quality
and simply more compute bigger scale
indeed the sheer scale of compute way
more than 10 to the 25 floating Point
operations was so big that at one point
the EU classified that as presenting a
systemic risk so whether that scares you
or Hypes you let's see the results of
all of those flops here is just a quick
snapshot of a comparison on traditional
benchmarks between llama 3.1 405b and
GPT 4 GPT 40 Claude 3.5 Sonic as I'll
try to persuade you in a moment I don't
think these benchmarks quite capture the
Nuance differences between the models
but it certainly shows you that this new
quote open- Source model from meta is on
a par if not better than GPT 4 of course
it doesn't yet have all the fancy speech
in and speech out that gp4 Omni does but
technically we don't have access to that
yet either for that model I do think
it's worth noting though just for 10
seconds that we have a downloadable
model now that is as good or better than
the GPT 4 that caused such waves early
last year at the time people thought
that day might take 2 years or even 5
years but no it's here and yes meta are
still arguing that this series of models
charts a quote responsible path towards
the development of artificial general
intelligence I'll at least have a few
comments on that when it comes to my
private general intelligence Benchmark
just quickly why do I keep saying quote
open source well according to the
semiofficial open- source initiative the
definition of Open Source AI includes
the training data Providence where it
comes from how it was obtained the paper
on page four simply says from a variety
of data sources so even if you had the
budget you couldn't recreate llama 3.1
because you simply wouldn't know what
data they used indeed I did a video on
this for my new corsera course but just
remember that anytime you hear that meta
is committed to open source AI I mean
just look how many times in this one
paragraph Mark Zuckerberg used the
phrase open- source so why be shy about
the data they're using well as the New
York Times recently reported the data is
getting harder and harder to find
companies like Reddit and Twitter are
charging for their data and meta may not
have had permission for all of that data
and one theme you'll see throughout the
paper is using language models to
improve the performance of language
models using llama 2 for example to
filter the data used to train llama 3
that's just one example there are
literally dozens so you can bet that
llama 3.1 is being used to help train
llama 4 before you predict though that
this is setting off some form of
intelligence explosion remember that it
was just yesterday that Zuckerberg
admitted that the Llama models are
hemorrhaging meta money it's hard to
know in advance when something is good
enough that you're going to have a
product that billions of people use and
then when it's ready to to kind of be a
large business and I mean look we're all
spending you know a lot of capital and
and on basically training these models
so I I think that people are going to be
probably losing money for quite a while
um but but I don't know maybe maybe
maybe that'll all happen quicker I'm
it's it's it's hard to know exactly and
even open AI might be losing $5 billion
this year alone that's at least
according to a report released by the
information while I was filming the
video but we do know that L 4 is coming
and probably before the end of the year
how do you define AGI and do you get
there first well it's a good question um
we're basically already starting to work
on on llama 4 and our goal is to
completely close the gap with all the
others on that so um so I don't know I
do we do we get to AGI first I mean I
think that there will probably be some
breakthroughs between now and then it's
hard to just predict in a straight line
then you get to the more complicated
question which is like what is it I
don't know that there's like one
specific definition for this throughout
the paper they give away their recipe
for doing what they did having read both
the original llama paper and the Llama 2
paper this is quite different it almost
feels like they're much more confident
giving away the secret of large language
models they almost don't believe that
there's much of a secret source and
they're not scared of China and Claude
3.5 Sonic aside they've almost proven
that with this model and I must say that
there was one part of the paper that I
found especially Sensational they
developed scaling laws not just for next
token prediction loss but for Benchmark
performance or to somewhat translate
that how long to run the gpus to get the
Benchmark performance that they they
wanted given their flop budget they
predicted how the model would perform
and got it right only just slightly
underestimating final performance or in
their words this approach enables us to
predict Downstream task performance
given a specific number of training
flops for compute optimal models they
set themselves a compute budget and got
the Benchmark performance that they
expected it's almost a bit like you can
imagine a benchmark performance dial in
Mark Zuckerberg's office that he can
move clockwise at will while the money
lasts of course these Benchmark scaling
laws by the way extrapolate across four
orders of magnitude so are pretty
reliable in case you're wondering that's
where they got the quirky 45 billion
parameter number from they had the
compute budget looked at those Benchmark
scaling laws and assigned that number of
parameters on the right is the sigmoidal
scaling LW curve that they anticipated
and that followed on the ark challenge
that's not by the way the ark AGI
challenge that I've talked about on this
channel recently but it is legit
questions like this that you can see
here general knowledge and what they
call a reasoning challenge now just how
many benchmarks that scaling law holds
for is a question that I at least am
immensely curious about I'll come back
to benchmarks but the amount of detail
they went into down to the exact
hardware issues they had is quite
incredible rible they even knowe at one
point that temperature fluctuations
during the day impacted GPU Dynamic
voltage and slightly more concerningly
the fluctuations of power consumption
across the data center stretched the
limits of the power grid it does make me
at least wonder what the kind of issues
they'll have when they scale up another
50x now clearly because it is a 92-page
paper I am skipping over a lot I do want
to bring you the most interesting
highlights for example there was this
detail about how they obsessively
cleaned the data they found an annoying
problem that was too common in their
data overly apologetic tonal issues
phrases such as I'm sorry or I apologize
they didn't want that nor did they want
excessive emojis or exclamation points
back to that theme though of AI
improving AI they trained a code expert
model to help them find the highest
quality human annotations for code pages
on in the paper they say that they
trained a multilingual expert model to
collect higher quality annotations in
non-english languages and it seems
appropriate at this point to mention
that meta for the first time allow you
to use this Frontier Model to generate
synthetic data to improve and train your
smaller model they didn't allow that
before and nored companies like open AI
to the best of my knowledge so that
flywheel of models improving models is
now technically open to you now you do
have to be slightly sophisticated about
it though when they trained llama 3 405b
on its own generated data in programming
they found it wasn't helpful notice that
is different from those last two
examples this is the same model training
on its own generated data but when they
introduced execution feedback which I've
talked about quite a lot on this channel
it did enable the model to learn from
its own mistakes and anyone who has been
following this channel knows that I talk
often about verifier models and llama 3
indeed Incorporated that approach during
training in coding for example only
Generations that past syntax checking
and unit tests were used for fine-tuning
but for maths and reasoning the story is
even more interesting first they give a
curious definition of reasoning we
Define reasoning as the ability to
perform multi-step computations and
arrive at the correct final answer I'm
definitely going to leave a question
mark on that one because under that
definition wouldn't a calculator be
doing reasoning but the interesting bit
is how they say that training data on
the web shows a shortage of ground truth
correct chains of thought for reasoning
and math but those are essential for
guiding the model how to break down the
problem step by step and reach the final
answer in other words most online text
contains results and Analysis not the
chains of thought involved in coming up
with those results then they quote
Direct ly from the let's verify
step-by-step paper that I've talked
about many times on this channel and
they go on to say the following they
identified mathematical skills where the
model underperforms and actively Source
prompts from humans to teach the models
such skills and then they use the model
llama 3 to check the reasoning steps
behind a step-by-step solution in other
words training a model to recognize good
steps in a reasoning chain they could
then filter the training data where
those intermediate reasoning steps were
incorrect so not just the final results
the reasons used to get those final
results they wanted to eliminate invalid
reasoning traces and for the hardest
prompts they even used Monte Carlo
research a bit like alphago with those
process-based reward models to generate
valid reasoning traces translated they
searched as hard as they could to find
the best reasoning steps to teach the
model reasoning and at this point I can
hold off no longer from talking about my
own private Benchmark what I call Simple
bench to test general intelligence
reasoning and there are a few things I
love about this Benchmark obviously I am
ridiculously biased so take this with a
pinch of salt but this is actually the
Benchmark I rely on to test the real
reasoning intelligence of models first
it's fully private so it hasn't been
contaminated at all second it is
rigorously vetted not just by me but by
side experts with more to come if even
one mistake makes it into the final 100
or 200 questions I'll be pretty pissed
off but third and I think most
interestingly even the best models as
you can see fall well well well behind
the performance of humans as I have
anecdotally tested them I'll show you
one example in a moment which of course
won't make it into the final Benchmark
but for me it has been the most reliable
Vibe test that I've seen so far now I
will be testing the models again using
self-consistency but for now we have
Claude 3.5 Sonic way ahead at 32% Lama
405b at 18% well ahead of both versions
of GPT 4 and Gemini 1.5 smaller models
by the way in case you're curious like
GPT 40 mini score 0% and here is one
example that the new llama model
actually usually gets but GPT 40
basically never gets it comes from the
spatial intelligence section of the
Benchmark and involves placing four
whole ice cubes into a fire then some
more ice cubes Into the Fire and then
the question ends with how many whole
ice cubes can be found in the fire at
the end of the third minute I even add
in pick the most realistic answer and no
the model doesn't pick zero reflecting
that none of the ice cubes will be whole
or even still there after the third
minute most models of course go down a
rabbit hole of calculations now
admittedly this was one of the easier
questions on the Benchmark and if you
add things like think about this
carefully or this is a trick question
the models can sometimes get it but I
know the models well enough now that I
can create genuine spatial temporal
linguistic or social questions that no
amount of warnings allow the models to
get right and yes that's still with
humans scoring near perfectly how so
well it's because of course the models
are are modeling language they're
language models they're not reality
simulators they don't actually visualize
things in their head or think about
problems in the same way that we do so
how would a model like llama 3 ever get
a question like this right well it's
because I can leave let's say linguistic
Clues crumbs to allow them to infer the
answer even if they can't simulate the
situation testing if you will their
ability to pick up faint signal am the
noise if I remove all signal models
score zero with humans still scoring
almost perfectly but with just faint
signals I can separate the smart models
from the less smart models I'll be
totally honest I wish I could go through
all the 100 plus questions with you
because they're pretty fun but then of
course it would leak into the training
data inevitably and contaminate the test
now I have made The Benchmark functional
so I can change the numbers but still I
want to avoid that if possible now I get
it many of you are thinking that was a
very long way of saying that llama 405b
is good not quite as good as Claude 3.5
Sonic but better I think in text at
least than GPT 40 now you could say that
part of this Benchmark is somewhat
adversarial and meta on page 33 talk
about how adversarial tests cause
significantly worse performance than
non-adversarial ones what they mean by
that is that in some of the benchmarks
that they used even a single distracting
sentence at the end of a question caus
significantly worse performance than
simply asking the question if the model
was actually thinking about the question
that shouldn't happen and the paper
highlights this without actually
suggesting a solution for mathematical
reasoning and question answering however
the adversarial performances are
substantially lower than the
non-adversarial performances this
pattern is similar or pre- trained and
postt trained models full stop so much
to cover so I'm going to move swiftly on
to contamination through fascinating
word matching or engram checks they
found that contamination was Rife in
traditional benchmarks and these
contamination scores in this column
actually underestimate the problem they
excluded benchmarks from this chart when
the clean set had too few examples or
because the observed performance gain
when they cleaned the data set showed
extreme extremely erratic behavior and
they go on to describe the MML even when
they allowed for a higher threshold of
eight-word overlap between the training
data and the test it gave such high
contamination scores that it was
impossible to get a good performance
gain estimate so they couldn't even
really estimate how much contamination
was affecting the MML U scores it seems
like private benchmarks such as those
from scale Ai and indeed mine will be
more common in the future here was the
ranking for example in math by scale AI
with Claude 3.5 Sonic in number one
position at a glance human comparisons
leading to leaderboards like those from
lmis seem to be a bit more problematic
even though samman said that we now have
GPT 40 mini matching GPT 40's
performance in my own experiments and
let me know what you think in the
comments it's not even close having mini
beating Claude 3.5 Sonic just seems
shocking to me now lmis have addressed
that and said that they're going to
release a random 20% subset of those
battles so I will look at that with
interest back to the paper though and
here's another way that llama 405b does
seem to be better than its Rivals it has
a long context of 128k tokens or around
100,000 words now other models of course
have more than that but that's not why
it's better it's when it's asked
questions that rely on scouring through
that long context that it performs
better now annoyingly they didn't
compare it to Gemini 1.5 Pro but here it
beats GPT 4 GPT 40 and Claude 3.5 Sonic
significantly what is this infinite
bench ing QA well as you'd expect I
tracked down that paper and read it in
full and a typical question from that
Infinity bench was this with details
stre throughout a story the length of a
novel they asked what color dress did
person a wear when a met B for the
second time so the model would obviously
have to track when a met B for the first
time time then the second time and what
color dress they were wearing on that
llama 3.1 crushes Claude 3.5 also when
there are multiple needles in a hay
stack a bit like if there's four
passwords strewn throughout a long
document can't do this quite as well as
GPT 4 apparently or even llama 3 a
billion parameters randomly but does far
better than Claude 3.5 Sonic it does
seem a bit random to me to not compare
it to Gemini 1.5 Pro when that's its
specialy long context but anyway now I
will give some more credit to meta for
this they gave plenty of win loss human
comparisons with GPT 4 not only in the
paper but also on the website of the
Llama 3 release and most of those
comparisons were actually unfavorable
that's commendable honesty to include
charts which make your model seem less
good in the middle you can see llama 3
losing out to GPT 40 most of the time no
actually it's all of these comparisons
across English reasoning coding Etc now
again as we've seen human at a glance
evaluation can't always be trusted
though now though for a word on safety
and they claim that the violation rate
has dropped significantly for llama 3
compared to its competitors now normally
a lower violation rate for safety would
lead to an increased false refusal rate
when they refuse to answer simple
innocent questions basically but
actually it still has a pretty low false
refusal rate and they make this point
that it is critical to consider false
refusal as a counter metric because a
model that always refuses is maximally
safe cough cough claw 3.5 Sonic but not
always helpful the reference I'm making
there is that clawed very frequently
compared to other models seems to refuse
my innocent questions anyway so false
refusals are definitely a thing and I'm
glad meta are aware of it and again
commendable honesty they admit that
llama 3 is on average more susceptible
to prompt injection compared at least to
gp4 or Gemini Pro but it's better
apparently than mixed trial but there's
a wider point on safety that I do want
to note it was only around a year ago
that Mark Zuckerberg was receiving a
letter from two senators in America
concerned about the leak of llama 1
talking about its potential for spam
fraud malware privacy violations and
harassment now clearly that letter went
nowhere because they subsequently
released not only llama 2 but llama 3
open weights and downloadable and again
on the safety Point Leopold Ashen
Brunner will be having a fit because he
says there's no point keeping models
closed because adversaries like China
will simply steal the models anyway on a
thumb drive so when I see letters like
this from a couple of days ago to Sam
Alman signed by around six Senators
asking him if he has indeed committed
20% of their compute budget to safety I
just have a slight suspicion that open
AI might completely ignore this and
completely get away with it I also want
to commend meta for being much more
rigorous in how they pre-check models
before release they got a set of
volunteers and saw if there was any
uplift in their ability to create or at
least ideate about chemical and
biological weapons basically when they
had access to llama 3 versus having no
access both groups did have the internet
at least and the analysis of these
results showed no significant uplift in
performance related to usage of llama 3
and honestly that doesn't surprise me
too much given how much data filtering
went on count me at least as being
surprised if biological or chemical
weapon data still made it into the final
model I would hope not at least to their
credit open AI did a similar study
almost 6 months ago which I talked about
on my patreon AI insiders now the vision
speech and video parts of llama 3.1
aren't yet available Zuckerberg
described some sort of mess up but
didn't go into into much more detail but
they did have one interesting conjecture
in the paper you might remember how
Gemini 1.5 Pro and GPT 4 o are trained
from the ground up to be multimodal that
has advantages but meta contends that a
compositional approach as in separate
models is actually in some ways more
advantageous apparently it's more
efficient during inference obviously we
can all judge this when it comes out but
I do note that gome brown said that GPT
40 didn't turn out as well as they hoped
with multimodal reasoning here were the
final results though in a benchmark I do
pay attention to the mmu you can see
that llama 3 with vision scores
64.5% versus claw 3.5 68.3% GPT 40 is
better at 69.1% and I can believe that
and very quickly on the video data that
meta used for training llama 3v well
they don't say it but they strongly
imply they're using Instagram reels now
anyone who knows can correct me but the
duration and resolution of the videos
does seem to hint at that if that's true
well then like Google they can of course
Flex those muscles of the masses of data
that they have that people like open AI
wouldn't necessarily have yes by the way
they are working on speech generation as
well as speech understanding so you
should be able to talk eventually to
llama 3.1 just like we were promised
with GPT 40 they even claimed that their
speech recognition is better than
whisper V2 and for multilingual
scenarios whisper V3 now admittedly this
experiment was using whisper V3 but just
look at the speed in this case using Gro
that these smaller llama 3 models can
act at located can you tabularize it for
me can you add a duration
column can you remove the end times from
the time column
can you make the duration in
minutes and can you move the duration to
between the time and stop
column can you add lunch and dinner at a
nice
restaurant you know what I changed my
mind make it
Vancouver of course for time reasons
I've got to draw this video to an end
but there were countless more
experiments with training models
revealed throughout the paper and
speaking of tracking experiments you may
already know that AI Labs including open
AI have used weights and biases this
video sponsor to track Frontier machine
learning experiments as well as
visualize iterate on optimize and share
them but you might not know that weight
and biases now have weave a lightweight
toolkit to confidently iterate on llm
applications and that they produce free
prompt and llm agent courses on their
website and if you didn't know that do
let them know that you came from this
video the link is in the description and
so let's conclude with meta's conclusion
they say and I agree that in many ways
the development of high-quality
Foundation models is still in its
infancy our experience in developing
llama 3 suggests that substantial
further improvements of these models or
on the horizon they go on to admit that
they did explore more complex model
architectures and training recipes but
did not find the benefits of such
approaches to outweigh the additional
complexity that they introduce into
model development like you I can't wait
of course to compare llama 3.1 with
Gemini 2 and GPT 5 and they had the
right plan to ensure that llama 3 was
not accidentally overfitted on commonly
used benchmarks and that their
pre-training data was not only procured
but processed by a separate team that
was they say strongly incentivized to
prevent contamination of that
pre-training data the model's
performance on my simple bench does
imply that their Benchmark results
aren't fluky and they end with this we
hope that the release of llama 3
encourages the industry to embrace the
open in quotes responsible development
of AGI let me know what you think in the
comments and as always have a wonderful
day